hello everyone i'm grandmaster
dennis borish i'm back again with insane
in the end game
and today we are going to do something
special
uh we are going to take a look at a game
not from your favorite time period
but the favorite time period of a
pillsbury because he was a live man
now pillsbury had a match versus
showalter showalter was a decent player
but
not such a great one as pillsbury
because everybody knows what pillsbury
is
famous about m4 now before i
get into the nitty-gritty we are going
to be focusing
on a specific position of the carlsbad
structure
and the reason as i get
to that position you're focusing on this
one
oftentimes it wouldn't be strictly
speaking
end game more of a heavy piece end game
which is a bit more
uh complicated than your usual
simple rukan games and your
and gay man games so to say in this case
is
oftentimes it's all about
the controls and the pawn structures
so as the pawn structures come alive and
come to being you realize that
here your main goal is to undermine your
opponent's structure
so the next move isn't really shocking
from harry nelson pillsbury he jumps
right on in with knight e5
and what makes knight e5 special well
it's a novel idea at the times
and also was very successfully played by
pillsbury
therefore that is that night what we
call the pillsbury night
now showalter didn't
know that he has something to show but
he knew that he didn't want that night
to station there for long so knight g4
guess what we are going for mass
trades but as you'll notice even though
we'll get mass
trades of the light pieces there'll be
still ample play
for pillsbury to play for so bishop
takes
queen takes knight takes bishop takes a
g4
so the first things and most important
thing when you're playing
a heavy middle game you still middle
game slash end game
you still have to decide the direction
where you're going
you can always fall back to the classic
classic way of going with the carlsbad
minority attack but there are other ways
and in this case
pillsbury chooses another one he goes
for rook ae1
he is preparing the idea of f3
and e4 now for one thing f3 was
impossible because of the threat of
queen takes c3
but after rk e1 f3
will be on the agenda and e4 would
give a big advantage for example if h6
these pawns would start rolling
non-stop
so showalter realizes and in fact
kudos for surewalter who is not as well
known of a player
than pillsbury himself
you'd notice that he anticipates
his well-known opponent's ideas
so the very next question is
what to do to stop f3 and e4
and this is kind of important when you
can anticipate these plans
that's the moment you can tell you've
reached a very high level in your chess
so once f3 and e4 shows up
there is imminent trades on e4
and f takes e4 and
once those trades happen
then there is a pawn that becomes
extremely extremely weakened
and that is the d4 pawn so in this
scenario
show showalter decides to go queen f6
with the idea of eyeing the d-pawn
stopping pillsbury from rolling those
pawns in the center
if you're unfamiliar with these middle
game slash endgame structures
often if white gets that e and d pawns
rolling
there is no stopping those and white has
a crushing positional advantage
and that sort of means if f3 e4
is out the window you've got to look for
a brand new plan
so let's start thinking about this what
can
pillsbury lean back on if not
on the f3 for idea as we mentioned
there is threats on the d-pawn that
would be troublesome
so whenever you're trying to figure out
these um pawn structures and how you can
attack them
you always first have to find the
weakest link
now it's not the most popular game in
the tv shows but it was at some moment
and if you can't spot it
then you know the direction what y
should be going for
you look at these pawns they're very
difficult
to deal with that pawn is defended by
the
larsen knight or they used to say if you
get a knight on f8
there is no fear for checkmate and there
is nothing that you have to worry about
in this
scenario not on f8 no checkmate
ben larson one of the best players and
also the player who bobby fischer
himself
said well i could play number one
on team world but i'm going to give that
spot
to bent the prince
of dane so
we really don't have any
weaknesses in this case on the black
side of
things f7 g7 h7 all
well defended so if you look at this
position
what would be a potential target for
pillsbury to latch onto
so
so it can't really be the d-pawn
can be the c-pawn because they're all
defending each other
so that that cannot be the answer
the biggest weakness in this position is
the b7 pawn
the weakest link of this whole pawn
chain
and this will be crucial in all the
games that we're going to take a look at
that
classic classic minority attack comes
into fruition
but here pillsbury plays something that
is not the usual way
everybody goes b4
runs it down with a4 but b4
is showing your intentions immediately
in these type of positions black can
often go
queen d6 a4
well not necessarily a4 because that
would drop the pawn but let's say queen
b3
rook d8
a3 a5
this is the typical idea undermining
this structure
b5 and now black could go c5
relieving the pressure on that b7 pawn
and yes there will be a weakness on d5
but that's compensated by these loose
pawns
by white as well so when pillsbury was
deciding
which way to continue on with his
minority attack
he probably envisioned that b4 entails
some risks of this a5 b5
and c5 plan so even for a4
and what makes a4 such a great move it
does not show
white's hand also
it threatens to gain space you could
try to fix that b pawn and maybe even an
eventual queen b3
will put pressure on the b pawn there
a4 rookie 7 b4
and this is kind of the nuance and shows
how big of a talent
pillsbury was he knew that he wants to
go for the minority attack but didn't
want to give away
his intentions b4
rookie 8 b5 and we get the typical idea
black can rarely take on b5 because that
would leave the d5 pawn
chronically weak
queen g5 so
in general if you're attacking
that's a good thing but you have to
figure out what
showalter is on about so let's take a
look
what could show walter be planning to do
in this position
and pillsbury is pretty quick to react
to it
um
so there is obviously the idea of bishop
h3
is that the only threat that black is
threatening
in fact black has multiple threats not
just bishops
so bishop h3 is a great move but
let's say white is oblivious
to black's plans if you go bishop h3
i can go f4 and not only do i attack a
queen if your queen moves
anywhere to where square it's gonna get
captured
and queen g4 stops it but after king h1
that bishop is going to get captured and
that is not something that black would
want to have
so exactly right bjorn bishop f3 is the
bigger threat
blocking in the f pawn and now g3
is forced but then we have these typical
queen h5 queen h3
and queen g2 checkmates so this is very
dangerous
now pillsbury senses the danger and also
it's in his style
he lashes out with f4 chases the queen
away
but does create a potential weakness on
e3
between f6 queen d2
bishop f5
so in these type of crossbar structures
the pawns are the heart and soul
so the question is how can
nelson pillsbury continue on from
this position is there any threats that
he has to deal with right now
and it's i understand is somewhat
subjective
some feel a move is threatening and
others don't
but that is the subjective nature of
chess
and believe it or not even computers
understand that
that uh there are moves that have the
equal value
so subjectivity is objective
in this game
so the question is if there's any threat
on e3
as far as i can tell it's nothing
too strong we've got the queen and rook
defending
it so it seems to me
that we have it all under control so
first step
what you take in a position like this is
realizing if there is
a high red alert in your position and if
not
you continue on with your plans
so we are doing good let's continue on
with our plans
how can we undermine show walter's
position
in that case
well we realized that this pawn mine
itself not won't necessarily win the
game
like if they take of course they're
never gonna take
with the queen they're gonna take with
the pawn
you don't have enough pressure on the d5
pawn
yes you see this is becoming the next
weakest link
but even if you would try to double up
on the c file
going after that c pawn that ain't gonna
work out in your favor
because the e3 pawn is loose and
is very hard to deal with
but if you go rook f3 i'm not quite sure
what you're aiming to do in that case
well you do relieve that rook on e1
but just bringing the rook to c1 or b1
will not turn the tide in this game
so what pillsbury did is he played a5
with the specific idea of going after
the weakest link
so pillsbury actually does the purest of
the pure
minority attack in the carlsbad
he just gets rid of that b-pawn and once
that is gone
show walter's chances in an end game is
dissipating so let's see what happens
queen g6
takes 6 a6 and this is
big success by white
you are going to trade these bnc pawns
off
leaving the d pawn weak now of course
there is the c
pawn that we have to tend to but from a
strategical perspective
show walter is in trouble so c takes b5
knight takes b5 queen d7
so showalter is fighting back
he's trying to shoo our knight away
but he is to wake up to rude awakening
it is white to move and come up with a
splendid idea
so we succeeded from a positional
standpoint
that does not mean we can't use
some form of witchcraft i mean tactics
in these cases and pillsbury does not
shy away from
tactics if it's possible
so his next move is somewhat surprising
but
not so much if you have honed
your tactical skills
now if white would go knight c3 there is
this idea of b5
and even though there is this d-pawn
weakness
then eventually that b-pawn can become a
menace
and they can also gang up on the a pawn
so in this scenario
pillsbury came up with the spectacular
move of 8xb7
which goes to show even in the driest of
dry positions
there could be some tactical sequences
you can use
it takes b7 obviously you can't directly
capture
back because of knight d6 and you lose
the exchange
and of course the big question is what
happens in case of queen takes b5
rook b1 the rooks come in there in time
and the fact is black had all
that pressure on the b-pawn but in this
case the queen will have to move away
otherwise it's taken
and now i can promote takes
takes and that is just a winning
position
so here show walter had to go a6
chase the knight away still a very good
move knight c3
always closer to the center trying to
press the d-pawn
queen takes b7 and a rook b1
queen c6 now
it's time for us to take a look
and assess the position we got this
typical
pawn structure of the carlsbad but with
a big difference
of black not having this pawn chain
and pillsbury already committing his
pawn to f4
now it's obvious to the eye that
this f pawn is not a happy camper i'd
rather
want to be on f2 but in chess pawns
don't move
backwards sadly now
here again pillsbury comes up with
a very creative idea of defending the
e-pawn
without defending it
and again that shows that pillsbury was
quite a talented player
by the way in the long run it's still
beneficial and more pleasant for white
because blank has two weaknesses both of
them isolated
while white only has one pawn on e3 that
he needs to take care of
so whenever you're looking for these
tactical solutions
always try to
pinpoint the loosest or the weakest
piece your opponent has
so what is the loosest piece in show
walter's position
which piece in black's position is a
little bit loose
the queen yes the queen is a little bit
loose
so here pillsbury uses a very nice
tactical idea
goes rook fc1
now show vulture wasn't interested but
we are and we're curious
what's wrong with rook takes e3
there is a reason why this hasn't been
played
and quite a convincing reason let me
tell you that
it has to be a night move obviously
otherwise how are we going to
use the power of that rook
knight e4
i saw many of you were saying
knight d1 but 91 there's rookie one
check
if you take i take with a check and that
is sad news so takes takes your king is
under attack you can't you don't have
time to take my queen
and if you don't stick i shall say away
with
my majesty and you're the one who's
losing
however in this case what has the
splendid tactical idea of knight e4
blocking the connection between the
rooks and attacking the queen
so either you move the queen away then i
take your rook
or you capture that knight but then i
take your queen
so knight e4 is a unique way of
punishing
for show walter's greed but of course
showalter said
no thank you maybe next time but not
today so he goes queen d6
no more tricks on the queen we've got to
defend it
now a lot of times we tend to shuffle
our rooks back and forth back and forth
but the better you get at chess you
realize it's not going to improve your
position
so here pillsbury goes knight d1 which
looks very passive
but it defends the e pawn
for an eternity and after
there's no way you can attack that pawn
unless
unless showalter somehow shows up
with this long range maneuver which will
take
time and is unlikely to happen
in the close future goes knight g6
knight g6 obviously sets up some neat
little tactics
and pillsbury who has been very diligent
with his tactical tricks himself
is not going to fall for one g3
h5
so we now get into a situation
where we want to get
and put some pressure on show walter
spawns
and that is critical in all types of end
games you're looking at
basic rock and games heavy piece rokan
games like this one
in both cases that's the most important
thing
identifying the target and going after
it
so first we just need to identify
targets
preferably not moving targets and
pawns that might fall in the long run it
might not fall in like a couple of moves
like two or three
but it may fall in like five six
so which one of those spawns would be
the ones
we would go after
yeah d5 d5 is obviously
the key weakness and the pawn
that we would like to win the most
because if that falls
sadly there'll be another weakness on a6
and that'd be the end of the game
so the five and the question is should
we go for the a pawn
or should we go to the for the h pawn
show walters faced queen e2
that's very sync i'm going to attack
your h-pawn but that
i wasn't really attacking really i was
after your d-pawn there
and later on i might put pressure on the
a6 one
like those are the clear two targets we
have
pieces around just like with
the miley cyrus effect generally
you can only go after pawns
that are visible bonds that you only see
in movies and shows
difficult to meet difficult
to reach the deep on a pawn
clear targets you can go after those
so h6 h6
knight f8 so
here you've got to get grand master
moded
we decided which pawn we were attacking
we're going after it
rook c5 so pillsbury is going after the
d-pawn now
rook d8 rook c1
not only getting the control
of the open c file
but strengthening his position as well
now he could consider going rook a1
but there would be a little bit of
discontinuation of the plan
like a little bit of a lack of
congruence
normally you want to go after the d-pawn
if you go here
you're sort of mixing ideas
you should strictly be going one
direction
rook c1 g6
queen f3 knight e6
all right so this is a critical position
again surewalter is trying to shoo
away our rook how should we react
well clearly we've got to do something
about this threat
we definitely love to maneuver around
sure
but our rook is hanging and yeah it's
good to be
generous but not on the chessboard you
can be too generous
you may as well lose your queen in that
case
you can go rook c6 you can go rook a5
pressing those bombs but for the moment
we can sort of say that
black has stabilized somewhat right
mic is stabilized a little bit
why does black stabilize well black
stabilized
because white pressure
is nullified by
the rook and queen it's all guarded
there's
nothing we can do about it so far
one of the ways of
going and conquering a castle is to put
it under siege
and that's exactly what pillsbury does
he puts show walter's defenses
under siege
so he's trying to get rid of all of
those defenders
that have been over protecting the
d-pawn
so how did he do that
this is a critical moment don't feel shy
if you feel you gotta pause and think
about it
is is very important and this marks the
big difference between even
grand masters and legends
you may play moves such as rook c6 rook
a5
and they're definitely decent moves
but rook c8 is a whole different
universe he is undermining show walters
defenses
and that is more important
so rook c8 is the move played by
pillsbury
king g7 rook takes
knight takes rook c5
and now everything is collapsing you
can't really go rook d7
i go knight c3 and i win the d-pawn and
that is all because your d8 rook is gone
i could bring this other rook in bring
this
knight in and not win it even if you go
back a little bit
just notice there was some pressure on
the pawn
you really don't didn't have a chance to
maneuver around but after this trade
96 was played but after this trade
knight c3
could happen and you have direct control
over that square so in desperation
show walter plays knight e6 now
when we say desperado it does not
necessarily mean it's a bad move in fact
it is probably the best practical chance
that he could use he's saying okay you
may as well win the pawn
but at least your pieces will get a
little bit jumbled up
takes with the queen you can take the
rook
because i take your queen queen b6
rook c1 queen b4 and
show walter does what you see in plenty
of crossing games
and by other very tenacious defenders
he's trying to muddy waters he's trying
to lurk around
his opponent's king
so what white needs to do is
to consolidate the situation make sure
nothing funky happens
i can quite consolidate here
so right now your king really doesn't
have
too many guardian pawns sheltering your
king
and if you don't have guardian pawns
well
then the other other bodyguards have to
do what they have to do
they've got to step it up they have to
substitute
these defenders usually you have f2 and
g3
pawns shielding the king but right now
they're not around
pawns don't move backwards as we know
knight f2 very good knight f2
not only provides shield for the king if
it ever wants to go
up to g2 it also covers up this square
on e1
so black can never go queen e1 check
which was a big threat
earlier like this was a big threat to
deal with
so knight f2 now here show walter makes
a mistake
but it's a mistake that is reasonable he
thinks that he
is going to win something
it's a double attack which 90 percent of
the time does
win use some material not in this case
so we hit the 10 percent territory
now queen d2 again
falls smack into a typical typical
tactic by pillsbury so even though we're
looking at
heavy weight and heavy peace and games
you can notice that there's still plenty
of tactics involved
so let's try to find what pillsbury did
in this scenario
and let's try to get a bit deeper than
just considering one move let's let's
calculate
it is always about sequence of moves
now i don't expect everyone to go three
four moves
deep but at least to move deep is
a ballpark of having an idea of a
position when you're saying
i'd like to play here you don't really
have a continuation of follow-up
that means you still have to work on
calculating skills
so right now we are being double
attacked by that queen
so we can do two things we can
try to defend both at the same time or
try to counter-attack our opponent's
king
on g7
and notice something peculiar the queen
and anything that's on f6
is in a night distance exact
night distance see what you will
but that seems like
what we're looking for
it's just one night distance away
so queen e5
f6 and here pillsbury
does not miss a chance like this
queen takes f6 that is correct
king takes knight e4 check and who said
that you can't do tactics in the en game
king f5 knight takes d2
g5 d5
takes takes knight takes f4
e takes king takes f4 still a desperado
here pillsbury plays rook c5 which is
inaccurate
so this is by no means a perfect game
if showalter would have played king e5
the king could come back and if you go
knight c4 there's king
d4 and suddenly it's draw
if you move here i take on d5
however he was winning here he could
have gone
rogue d1 obviously putting the rook
behind the pawn
and supporting the palm push if you go
king e5
there is no way to
cross over from d4 to c5
the pawn is defended and the pawn is
going to march down the port
but show walter misses this last chance
but now
pillsbury is accurate plays knight c4
takes away that square
king e4 d6 and now it's too late
because after king d4 there's rook c7
you can't really capture because the
pawn is going to promote now
so rook c7 rook d8
d7 and this runs into rook c8
where black resigned because if you take
there's knight b6 check
fittingly another counter-attacking move
by the knight just attacking
both the king and the rook and therefore
showalter resigned so very interesting
game by pillsbury where
he combined tactical ideas with
positional ones
undermining the cause bad structure of
show walter
and then making sure his pawns won't
fall
due to these tactical tricks of rook fc1
ideally putting pressure on the queen
and then
slowly slowly undermining black's
weaknesses on d5
and a6 so the other game i wanted to
show
is this game between anatoly karpov
and yubamir yuboyevic um
yuboya ryuboyevich was a candidate
so a candidate he was playing at the top
of his game
was very close also to qualify
but narrowly missed out on that chance
but unfortunately this time he's facing
the legendary anatoly karpov who
needs no introduction a world champion
and quite a veteran winning plenty of
tournaments
even later in his career in the 90s
he was very very successful so let's
take a look it's again
your typical calls bad
rook b1 knight e4
and what you need to learn when you're
playing the carlsbad
with white that trades are not
necessarily your enemies
as the pawn structure will give you
ample compensation and ample play to
succeed
so you are just trying to undermine
black's position
and that is very much crucial stakes
takes b4 a6 a4
this is your typical minority attack
bishop f5 now just because
we looked at the pillsbury game i'm very
curious if you can guess
karpov's very next move you will not be
surprised
it goes 95 obviously
so there were times
people did not know who pillsbury was
but with karpov you could be sure
he knows the ideas and those little
information that you need
to become one of the best players he has
a very very
good positional style and he has
a good sense for nuances now
trades wouldn't actually help
you boyevich because you still would be
facing off ideas such as b5
and then you will have to
defend it tenaciously so instead
yuba yavich goes rook d8 rook fc1
knight g6 bishop takes e4
so karpov is not afraid of trading and
um
in general trading isn't good for your
position
but because of the specific nature
of the cause bad structure white
actually gets winning chances by playing
this way
normally if you have a better position
you want to keep as many pieces on the
board or pawns on the board
as you possibly can should take c4
bishop takes c4 knight takes e4
and interestingly enough black was doing
more or less okay here but
does the impulsive move of d takes e4
if he would have been knight takes e5
his position would have been
fairly balanced maybe slightly worse but
not more than that
and again that's kind of shows how
slippery positional chess can be
one single bad trade might
just spell at the end of your game so d
take c4
a very logical decision but a bit too
impulsive
by yuboyevich who is well known for his
creative aggressive play d
takes c4 knight takes
h6 b5 also notice
that the idea i mentioned earlier in the
pillsbury game c5 is not even on the
agenda
i have all of my guys
pressuring the c5 square that's not
gonna happen
all right so before we jump in
to this game deeply let's just
pinpoint potential targets in black's
position
it's very important when you're playing
more of a strategical game
to identify the weaknesses in the
position
here are the potential targets here
well it is the b7 pawn obviously we are
going there and rolling down the board
to get closer to the b-pawn that's why
we have
the rooks sort of ready to infiltrate
and attack that pawn
and that's a great point apart from the
b7
pawn this e pawn is
super duper weak now
this is one of those exceptions
this one the computers understand but
a lot of times humans are better at
identifying that this e4 pawn
is going to be a source of trouble
carpool was
extraordinarily good with that realizing
that yes i have no ways of winning this
pawn
it's doubly defended by the queen and
rook
i'm not gonna win it i'm not gonna win
it in one move not gonna win it in two
moves
not in five and not in ten but on the
twelfth move
i am going to win it and that's going to
be the end of the game
so b5 cb a b
now apart from realizing these
weaknesses
white got an extra ace in the pocket
and that's the d-pawn now that would
really be a big deal normally
but here it actually becomes a protected
pass pawn
which can eventually make a stroll down
to d8 rook d6
b6 b takes
and now we are at crossroads
should we try to push our d-pawns
try to undermine the e-pawn or maybe
pester the a-pawn
now i think corporal used a bit of logic
with his next move
um the
good thing for white is that any move
you make is probably reasonable
it doesn't necessarily have to be
accurate it's still going to be okay
because your pawn structure is so
superior to blacks
however karpov's next move is logical
as it just involves another piece
that wasn't to its fullest of potentials
white has these rooks controlling the
bnc
files but the screen on c2 isn't
particularly doing
too much so then for queen a4
with the idea of putting pressure on the
a pawn
and a little bit pressing on e8
as i said plenty of other moves are
good but queen e4 just looks right
as it opens up
new agendas for all of white's pieces
queen d7 queen takes d7
rook takes d7 now often times we make
the mistake
of continuing our plans like nothing
happened after a trade now that would be
a big mistake
here white should realize
that with the queens off the board the
situation has completely shifted
we've got to reassess our plans and come
up with a new one
and because of the nature of the
position you could even just strategize
it's not always
about moves but about plans and
ideas sort of putting pieces pawns
under siege and if that works
you're probably going to dominate
so karpov goes rook c5
stopping any pawn pushes and again
anticipates that this rook might be
useful
attacking the e pawn so
notice that karpov's moves never serve
only a single purpose they always serve
multiple purposes
now i see the question what about going
f3 undermining the e pawn
but then you would be trading away
yubo yavich's biggest weakness he'd be
so happy to give that e
pawn for another pawn but that is the
source of your advantage
if you trade it off if you trade your
opponent's weaknesses off
your advantage will be gone in a jiffy
through k7 doing the classical
end gameplay karpov goes no
you are not going anywhere with that a
pawn
king f8 and now he gangs up
on the a6 pawn
can black play f5 we're going to talk
about in a bit
it is definitely a move to consider
rook ea8 okay
so so far karpov's play was
very successful he has everything under
wraps
those rooks on the a file look
fairly sad they can't move they
literally can't move
but a position isn't winning
so our job in this position
is to create a second plan or second
front
if you will to win this game
let's try to find it
so we talked about the apon being a
target
but is there anything else we could try
to go after
is there any other weaknesses you can go
after
now you could bring the king
and in end games that's not a bad plan
however if you go this direction of king
f1
king e2 king d2 it takes
months to get to your destination
enter karpov's h4
and i'm not sure that carpool was a big
fan of jimi hendrix but he is definitely
crawling
out his window just to take
the e-pawn and yes usually you go king
f1 e2
but in this case it's just way more
beneficial
to just find an easier
shortcut towards the e pawn now f5 never
really
works because that would just drop
the g6 spawn and then it would drop the
f5 pawn
and with all these pawns dropping the
closer you get
to a lost end game so h4
king e7 king h2
on track to e4 king g3
king c7 rook b2
again notice it's not what
karpov wants to do but what you boyevich
shouldn't be able to do this is making
sure the king
can't actually activate
the rock so the king could get to be b7
maybe you could activate the rook but
carpool has
no game for that
rook b7 rook c5 check
king b8 top of nose you have the
advantage
you are having everything under control
you go okay too
and now you don't trade
because these pieces are very passive
and just having a past one isn't going
to win you a game
so key is seven king f4
so our big plan is coming to fruition
b7 rook b2 here
rook c6 just twisting another one
on black's position black is still
hopelessly tied up
it's not just that white is better but
black just practically has no moves
rook h8 and as the rook moves away
he takes this chance to win this pawn
a5 takes king b7
rook a6 rook takes h4
king g3 and again you might be saying
hey
you have each one upon well that is true
but
is karpov under control like having the
position under control
totally all of your yuboyavich's pieces
are tied up
and in fact is completely lost
by this moment king c6
splendid tactical spot by
the black player and black grandmaster
you can't take any of them
you're going to lose one of those
but karpov is
very good at calculating maybe it's not
what he's known for
but if it comes down to pure calculation
he is up top at that
time so check king b5
and now he trades king h2
just goes back job is done you are
going to go full pac-man mode on the g
and f pawns king takes a6 rook takes f7
and it is
game over so quite a nice game
by anatoly karpov showing
that in the long run you always
always want to
latch on your opponent's weaknesses and
once they're tied up
you don't ever wanna let it go
thank you so much for watching and hope
you learned a bit about how to deal with
the carlsbad and games goodbye